i'm good bro i'm good what do you say
you uh
please the crowd for like 30 seconds
while i let everyone know on the story
that we're live
all right
show them around bro show them around
show them what you were showing me
princesses watching
inshallah i don't know if you guys heard
me probably lagged out for a second
um
[Music]
oh yeah
that's that's all i have to say
bro you literally like though for the
whole thing
oh really i didn't say didn't give me
no you i can hear you now
okay
yeah
well
what i said is uh
brothers and sisters
hope everything is good
wherever you are in this dunya in this
world
uh
yeah a man in many ways huh
i guess i'll show you guys where i'm at
i am
at the moment in thailand i'm in the
mountains
this is
the view
at the moment
i don't know if you guys can see that
masha allah
oh this is nothing by the way from what
i saw yesterday subhanallah
garlic salaam alaikum bro
i noticed you wrote it uh
oh no amount of many words i think you
meant amount of few words
man of few words but many sounds
isn't that right bro
hmm there we go
all right bro so what's the motive how
long are we here in the mountains
uh here for
another day
heading out tomorrow
and uh inshallah we'll come back
me and the brother
um in a week we'll probably stay up here
for like two to four weeks inshallah
ma shallah
um
what's one of the what's one of your
favorite things out here
in the mountains or in just thailand in
general
well i thought we weren't we aren't
going to say where you are but
in the moment i mean i already said it i
already said it's so helpless
in the mountains
uh well the mountains i said in the
video that i made yesterday
i don't know i just had this like
this feeling like you know when i became
muslim and i told you i had the waves
going through my body
yeah i was looking at all the mountains
and like
bro i had the same waves go through my
body as like when i became muslim and
i just started crying bro and
and
when i saw everything i was like yeah
like i'm i'm ready you know like i'm
ready to die like if whenever is my time
like i'm ready like a lot just made it
easy for me in that moment
so alhamdulillah bro
mashallah how cold is it bro
it's um
[Music]
i think it's like 10 degrees celsius
well for you that's very cold
well what's 10 degrees celsius
that's not cold at all it's a fair night
and fahrenheit i don't know fahrenheit
bro i'm from canada you know that
i don't know man
it's 10 degrees celsius
in phuket is definitely like a tropical
beach climate so like being in the
mountains is definitely different it's
crazy man like you'll be driving
and like during the daytime it's hot
but then whenever you reach like the
shade as you're driving in the streets
bro since it's a jungle
yo the temperature drops like 20 30
degrees
the moment you hit the shade
it's crazy but
when you're driving the the scooters out
here
what about uh our brother there how's he
doing
oh
i love blessing bro he's doing great he
broke his phone yesterday so if he
hasn't reached out to you or anything
it's because it is phoned and snapped up
damn subhanallah does the phone still
work or is it just the screen
the screen is done i think the phone
works though
what phone is it
um it's like that new new samsung
oh he's android bro
he's an android boy bro we'll convert
him soon don't worry
probably he has all the apple stuff he's
got the
apple earbuds or the airpods he's got
the macbook pro he's got
he's got all that stuff he just likes
the android more than the iphone guys
let us know bro if you're watching it
this far
what are you comment down below if your
hashtag android or iphone but
you can't convert everyone bro that's
the unfortunate state of reality you
could have an iphone you can think
iphone superior and we all have a
reasons but some people just want
androids bro i know i'm starting a war
right now but it's you can't do anything
about it just like when you find the
truth bro and you find a straight path
you can't save everyone bro
and i think this is a wonderful segue
into a topic today that a lot of
brothers and sisters have been reaching
out hey i revert to islam alhamdulillah
hey i'm trying to you know work on my
deen but so and so my friend my spouse
my parents i just can't guide them bro
what should i do
i tried the whole you know lead by
example and
alhamdulillah i tried you know giving
them a little bit of dawah it's not
really working i don't know what to do
um
like what do i do bro i can't save
everyone but shouldn't i at least try
like where do i draw the line so
being a new reaver yourself bro i want
to know from you
um what's your experience been like bro
understanding that in the beginning it
was just like okay let me save myself
but now you know there's it goes deeper
than
that i'm still trying to save myself
same here bro me
i think it's at the end of the day like
trying to save other people is um
kind of silly if you can't save yourself
you know so you should focus on yourself
and
by doing so it it's this analogy that my
sister gave me a long time ago where
imagine you have this cup and you fill
this cup up
with the water
right
every time that you give someone
something
you give them attention you give them
love whatever it is like you're giving
them a little bit of your water
and if you don't take the time to refill
that cup or that cup is going to run dry
real quick
and if you put into this case scenario
it's like well if
you can't save yourself how can you save
others
so at the end of the day this is like
i hate to say but me and uh the brother
here we were talking about this
and it's uh it's every man every woman
for themselves
but at the end of the day like you still
do your best to kind of like
help out
give back
and um
[Music]
try to give darwin through your actions
in whatever way shape or form that you
can to be honest with you
um
would you find that a lot of people
haven't saved themselves
or they're not doing anything to save
themselves and they're too concerned
about the faults of other people
oh yeah
100 it's it's the whole thing of like
you ever seen when people project
you know like when when they have a
problem and then they try to project
that on to another person and they try
to act like they don't have that problem
or like they they're superior or
or like oh they i don't i don't even
know how to explain everything but it's
like
it's almost like they got some stuck up
the ass stuff for love
but it's basically what it is man and
it's uh
when someone is sinning and doing
something and like they can't accept
that and they're trying to like
push that away from their own psyche
then it's almost like they
they put everyone on blast
that is uh having that same
thing that they are trying to put away
so
it's like a dude who's homophobic
but like proper proper homophobic
and
maybe he's really gay
you know but he's like proper homophobic
just hates gay people like with a
passion
and anytime he sees gay people he's over
here like flaming them and doing all
these things and it's like bro he's only
doing it because he's he feels some type
of way internally you know
um
i feel that bro
i want to say two things about number
one
uh
i think this was the fastest video that
we ever got demonetized brought along
about it bro for that number two i just
want to quickly say
i just want to quickly say there's a
there's a quote that i read somewhere in
a book i forgot where it was
alhamdulillah but it basically
summarized exactly what you were talking
about perfectly and it goes by
you spot it you got it
so if you look around you and you see
people with that and you're overly
concerned with that judgment you
particularly
make a note of that in everyone then you
probably have that you know what i mean
yeah
yeah
yo my bad about that man i i was um
i was just in the flow bro like because
yesterday when i made that well last
night when i made that video
and because i told you i would make it
so i definitely
kept my word
uh but when i was making that video like
i was just like all right yeah i'm just
gonna say whatever
no filter
so i'm still in that mode bro my bad
now you're good bro i love you about the
creep bro it's just we got to get used
to it bro we got to get used to it not
even for uh
just uh
the
demonetization and all that but just in
general bro as
speakers bro
yeah
but i will go as far as to say that some
of the words that we say as speakers are
fine
even if we're giving a hook but a
massager that's fine but youtube bro
they're on another level of you know
their standards
it's the false high-off for me bro you
know they'll post the most ridiculous
stuff
on youtube and it won't be flagged but
then we could say
you know
some word that angel said like five
minutes ago and it'll get flagged for
that
subhanallah
see though let's see i hear the birds
tripping bro
there's a lot of birds here there's cows
in this rice field
there's random dogs everywhere random
dogs and cats
marshall
so yo what's the what's the diet looking
like right now
over here in thailand yeah like where
you are in the mountains what do you
guys eat
bro whatever i can get my hands on
someone's going to take that out of
context bro and get us a strike bro so
do you want to elaborate on that
so whatever food is available
and uh when uh
this village right now it's a lot of
muslims
beautiful masjid
and the imam
and mom's only i think 19 years old
masha'allah
mashallah may allah bless him he's got
the most beautiful voice i've heard and
um
yeah but the diet like
we we might eat thai food
or we might eat uh
like chicken biryani
befriending we might have like
just a street food
um we had indian food the other day
which was
it was very nice no no well enough of
that man let's let's get to like the the
real talk of the video
let's get it bro i mean we already you
know edged over it just very lightly
though about uh how you can't save
everyone now i had another question on
my mind bro for you and i always wanted
to ask weaver this
but
given all the circumstances that you've
been through right
you know how we're talking about saving
ourselves and saving other people but
then we also talk about the problems
that we see like a lot of people they
haven't saved themselves yet and they
haven't worked on themselves but they're
out here judging everyone crucifying
everyone in public and
not doing proper dawah in the siha but
they're just out here trying to get
everyone almost like the haram police
so to speak you know there's nothing
wrong with it but there's a way to do
things and they they laughed at other
so
as a reaver bro
what was some of the most
i don't want to say annoying but just
things that
brothers probably had good intentions on
that they they did to try to guide you
try to help you try to teach you
something but
the way they did it wasn't proper like
what are some of these things so i think
that a lot of the brothers and sisters
watching this that they do want to you
know guide a lot of people they'll keep
these things in mind perhaps
uh when
brothers would try to enforce things
you know it's like i get it you have the
best of intentions you probably have a
good heart when you're trying to tell me
these things
but i'm new i'm a reaver like
this is still all very new to me and
when you try to enforce things and then
like
there was no like oh
you know take your time i was like no
you have to do it like this
it leaves a bad taste
in one's mouth and and you don't want to
be the reason
why someone leaves islam
you know and of course like at the end
of the day like that decision is on them
but you will have
a lot of impact
if you are spending time around this
person
so you just got to choose what you say
and how you express yourself
just wisely you know like of course they
already read it they're already muslim
um they're not going to be perfect
they're going to be all over the place
just you know you want for them what you
want for yourself
and think of them like a newborn baby
i get your little brother or your little
sister
like if your little brother your little
sister was like let's say um
one year two years old three years old
like would you really try to rush
everything on to them or would you
take your time and just kind of like
hold their hand like allow them to take
those first few steps then then kind of
show them everything else along the way
you know what i'm saying um
no i agree bro
i also feel like a lot of people don't
understand the amount of fitness that we
have today
and
they're not realistic do you know what i
mean
there's nothing wrong with giving dawah
and wanting the best for others bro
but you got to be realistic bro you got
to be realistic
like a lot of people they haven't oh i
see that i see that smoke coming on bro
you saw that right you're looking like
charizard right now bro make that make
that sound charge that makes bro
all right
yeah we
bro somebody better send a super chat
for that bro that was that was
definitely some that should be some
patreon content right there bro that's
not supposed to be some youtube content
but
it's a snippet it's a snippet bro it's a
taste of what you get a patreon bro what
is on patreon bro
get exclusive content you get content
early
you get some extra stuff behind the
scenes
make your way over to patreon bro most
tiers start at five dollars a month bro
that's damn near free
you already know bro and you can help
keep our lights on bro
there we go there we go all right now my
next thing that i want to talk about is
allah guides whom he wills all right
some people have a very bad relationship
with this idea right they think that
okay allah is going to guide me when
allah wants therefore if i'm not on the
right path or if he or she is not on the
right path path allah just hasn't guided
them right and they almost get into this
victim mentality you're stuck for allah
that i'm not the way i am because allah
hasn't gotten me yet although it is true
that allah guides whom he wills
where is the flaw in their thinking bro
what do you think
i think the flaw in the thinking is they
believe that i feel like they don't
understand the whole thing about free
will correctly you know what i mean i
remember when you were new into islam
and a lot of people are new into some
they don't they don't fully comprehend
the grasp the understanding of free will
right they think that okay if allah
knows everything that's going to happen
if allah is in control of everything and
allah causes everything to happen then
allah is responsible for everything and
i'm not responsible at all when that's
not really the the correct way of
understanding things do you know what i
mean
it's the fact that we all have free will
right we all have free will every
decision you make is on you not me
not on her not your mom not your sheikh
not your friends nobody it's on you
except allah already knew was gonna
happen anyway so allah didn't make you
do these things allah didn't make you
sin allah didn't make you do any of
these things that you think just
happened or or they were planned yes
they were planned they were written
because allah already understands and
knew that these things were going to
happen anyway i believe you sent me
something the other day that i'm not
sure how authentic this is but it was
something like our decree was written 50
000 years before we were even born
something like that
yeah yeah i'm gonna need someone to
check that but it's just basically like
way before we were even born the
predestination the decree the destiny
was already written so allah didn't
program it kind of like computer program
programmers write like a code and then
they click run it's not like that it's
allah wrote that it was going to happen
but we did those you know allah
allah transcends time bro time is a
is not a construct that allah operates
in right so allah transcends time allah
knew everything you're going to do
before you even do it so i believe the
flaw in their thinking is they think
that oh because allah already wrote
what's going to happen it was going to
happen anyway but it's not you did it
bro and that's where they fall into this
victim trap that you know allah made me
do it but it's not bro you made you do
it allah just knew you were going to do
it anyway which also shows that not only
did allah write what you were going to
do
allah also wrote down what you
uh what would have happened if you did
something else another option right
and also what would happen if you didn't
do it so all of these things are already
written you're completely the captain of
your ship in terms of
making all the choices with your free
will
so it also gives hope
in another aspect that it's not too late
to change your ways
yeah
yeah
before i became muslim
the
understanding that i had of this
was the whole
um
parallel
realities or alternate realities or
something like that
whereas like for each reality there's
like
just an infinite amount of other
realities
that could have so much different like
ways of like your reality
playing out basically
right and then becoming a muslim
i heard someone say that decree is
written because it happened and not
happened because it's written i like
that yeah i like that
and uh insert clickbait
we're doing good
yeah continuing what i was saying
it was uh
i think i said this in one of our videos
but
it's the video game analogy
where it's like
someone created the video game
right the person who created the video
game they know exactly all the possible
ways that the video game could play out
and
how it could end
right
but at the end of the day you're the one
playing the video game you're the one
that chooses like okay in this situation
right here where you have to choose to
uh save this dog or just
leave it there or eat the dog or
something like that right like whichever
you choose you're the one that chose it
but
what happens is already written it's
already coded it's already programmed
it's it's in the video game that's
that's how this dunya is like
allah created us
allah created every single possibility
already written it down but now he's
given us the free will so that we can
make those decisions so no one can
actually play the victim card here
marshall bro never thought of it like
that i remember the first time he
brought it up it didn't resonate with me
the way you explained it now so
jazakallah for that bro
right yeah
one thing that i also wanted to say
before you you let me know if you had
any questions or any insights after we
spoke on this was
anytime someone's on their own personal
journey right
i want you to understand that that's
your journey bro
things might become easier for you
in one aspect
and they're harder for you in another
aspect but for someone else they might
be harder for the first aspect and
easier for the second aspect
everyone's in their own journey and i
understand we got to save everyone so
you know
enjoying good and forbidden evil this is
this is completely 100 in line with what
we should be doing as muslims
however what does that even mean that
looks different for everyone so
you can't expect you know
someone else to uh
you know operate the same way that uh
another person would necessarily right i
read a quote bro i can't remember but it
was like if you judge uh an elephant
by its ability to swim like a goldfish
or something like that then it'll grow
up it'll live its whole life thinking
it's it's uh basically stupid raw that
it's not smart or it's incapable so it's
very similar to this i understand you
know this is different from for a lot of
shady things like things we should all
be doing but everyone grows at at their
own pace bro and just like allah said
you don't want to be the reason that you
know let me see that cat bro masha allah
you know the reason that like someone's
awesome
what is that
oh there we go that is what you call a
dog
do they have those in canada
not stray bro no way
i'll go continue continuing
watch that love bro
i can't i can't continue bro i'm too
excited thinking how after we're done
this stream i'm just gonna edit the
whole charizard thing that you did wrong
on butter ought to make a tick tock it's
going to go viral bro our career is
taking off after this
that's it bro
we're leaving without me behind too
because he couldn't make it for the live
stream that's it bro we're not looking
this
back
two t2n now t2m from the gutters to
charizard we made it guys
anyway bro speaking of charizard bro
what was your favorite pokemon
[Music]
um those
gyarados the red one the blue one
the red one
ah bro you so boujee bro i like
dragonite
it was
it's too thick
dragon was thick bro it kind of looked
like lugia
you know in the thickness lugia was
pretty cool
lugia was cool bro shiny lugia was even
cooler bro
looking back bro yeah they literally
designed those games for you to just be
addicted and hooked on 24 7. oh yeah
yeah bro i was just about to say
something like that
where it's like me and uh the brother
here
i wasn't gonna say his name but let's
keep that
low key we were talking about this
yeah and i was like um
[Music]
i'm trying to get to the point where
the things that i do everything is a
form of ibadah
and like i don't wanna
i don't wanna do something as like a
past time
that's a waste of time
you know and the only thing that's a
waste of time is something where
you're not doing it for the sake of
allah and like there's no real
there's no real barakah
there's nobody
or anything really in what you're doing
you know like yeah it's not haram
but it's not halal like it doesn't give
you any blessings it doesn't give you
anything it's just kind of like
taking your mind off whatever it is that
you're doing
so
like yeah i like video games yeah like
anime but it's
like it doesn't give me any barika
doesn't give me taqwa it doesn't give me
anything so
like i'm i'm actually thinking of like
just stripping that out
and including more other stuff that
there is buttaka in it
i don't know i was just thinking about
that you know
i like that bro i like that you know
also i wanted to make a quick note that
when someone sneezes there they gotta
say alhamdulillah but then
you you got to say something different
to them did you know that bro
yeah it's kind of like if if you sneeze
in the kofar they say excuse me right
but then no one else says excuse me they
say blessed and they say bless you
exactly so in islam if let's say i
sneeze right and i say alhamdulillah
then you have to say you are
allah
yeah
yeah
basically it's just like bless you you
know may allah bless you so
yeah
so that's the first thing second thing
is what you were saying bro it's
it's gold bro it's it's gold and it
reminds me that you know a lot of the
time when when
your friends are on their own journey
and your peers are on their own journey
and you get a little too caught up in
them
you
you miss
out on on the activities that you're
doing that are not really bringing you
closer to allah you know what i mean
like
uh is this what i'm doing conducive to
my growth is it gonna give me taqwa is
it gonna is it a nibada you know what i
mean but people are too concerned about
what tom dick and harry are doing bro to
be honest which is fine you know but you
gotta save yourself first check your own
household first and then worry about
someone else
yeah that goes back
to the main thing that we were talking
about
was like people have to focus on
themselves
whereas like you may have the best
intentions
but again if you can't help yourself how
can you help another
whoa
two doggies with me
there we go bro random dogs too bro
and this one right here
this one's just
crying
and he's got all the dogs on the field
but he's over here sitting next to me
trying to tell him to go play bro
he ain't listening
no
what you naming him bro
did you get that from doge
yeah okay
okay
hi bro is there anything on your mind
before we open this up to uh all the
viewers all the lovely viewers
let's open it up
before i open it up bro i know
while i do this uh do some quick masks
bro we got 52 viewers on the stream bro
how many likes should we have
[Music]
easily over 300.
quit complaining man go play
there we go and it's open to the public
bro
you say 3 000 bro
150 maybe 200 then it'd be 3 000.
yeah that makes sense bro totally
yeah
totally dude
bro i wish i wish y'all were out here
right now
you and ronnie
only two bronzer too
but uh inshallah we gotta wait till uh
summer later okay yo uh what we were
talking about over uh
uh
the phone with uh a potential
trip
right is that something that you're
comfortable speaking on right now
[Music]
sure
what's uh what's been decided so far bro
um
yeah it is very crazy isn't it
uh okay
so it's the dates that i sent you
and um
[Music]
yeah i think
i think that's pretty much it i gotta
talk to my brother today and see
okay
would you answer hanan's question bro
would you ever visit the uk
london
of course
i wanna i wanna see uk
is the ramy sleep yeah bro how do you
know yeah
he doesn't feel good he's sick right now
he's not feeling too well maybe
for me
yeah bro yo so uh hanan writes never
watched you last live bro
as as creators right as youtubers
ourselves
as a youtuber myself and you yourself do
you actually watch other people live
or not
i don't know
me neither also a lot of people are like
yo did you see this video bro after like
doing youtube like i don't even watch
other people bro i don't even watch us i
just we just make content to be honest
yeah like
not to sound boozy or anything
but you're either a
a creator or a consumer
and
you know i'm not gonna sit like to my
own or anything because like hey
sometimes i still watch
youtube videos but
not to the same degree when
i'm out here making them because like
once you make them you put in so much
effort into it
it's just kind of like yeah
i don't really know how to put it but
yeah
i hope you guys visit inshallah
inshaallah we do
you know
guys know uldu
bro
uh is bengali and urdu similar
uh not really bro there's some words
that overlap obviously but
it's pretty different bro pretty
different okay salam morning here
malaysia 8 47 am this topic reminds me
of one of my favorite videos from freak
but on education bro shameless plug
there we go
mashallah
i'm a consumer yeah most people are
consumers few people are producers just
like most people are viewers and some
people are creators right yeah it's not
a it's not a bad thing like we we go in
and out so don't think like oh i'm a
consumer like uh
you know what i'm saying we're all
consumers or something in creators or
something so me and anna might be
exactly creators for this but then we're
consumers for something else you know
what i mean and the things we're
consumers for those people are the
creators for that
yeah and you could be a consumer for
something that's good like islamic
content
no i agree i agree
how were you inviting your family to
islam especially with secular muslims it
is difficult okay so i want on how to
answer it first with your non-muslim
family and then i'll answer for my
muslim family
uh just through my actions
and like the little teachable moments
that arise
but i mean there's not much else how
much else that i can do as a
as a reverb
um
yeah honestly bro it's the same thing
for me it's just guiding them um
the fact that you wrote secular okay i
want to touch on this there's a lot of
muslims
you know what screw it i'm not going to
say a lot of muslims most people most
people most muslims unfortunately today
celebrating birthdays having christmas
trees going to christmas parties doing
all this bs right my job is just to
gently right very politely if i'm close
to them remind them right if they're if
they're ready for that because you got
to make sure they're receptive for that
you know what i mean
um if they're not then call us bro
forget it you're wasting your breath um
because the two forgot bro and you're
gonna be deemed as like someone like
very extreme and all that so just remind
them bro gently if they follow they
follow hamdulillah explain it you know
always have proof ready don't just be
like hey it's haram no one likes the
person that just says this is
never says anything further you know
never give something practical right so
similar to that i want to answer this
question too um any tips waking up for
fajr
i feel like as you were typing that
you already know you got to wake up for
fuji on time right and i feel like you
also knew what i was going to say in
response to that but it's okay because
you know we all need a little push a
little bit of encouragement i understand
but just do it there's no other way just
just do it just wake up set your alarm
very easy you can't wake up early sleep
early right um if you sleep really it'll
be easy to wake up early insha'allah and
have a goal bro go to the masjid if you
make a goal to go to the masjid on time
you can't sleep through it because the
masjid doesn't start when everyone comes
the masjid has a fixed time either
you're there or not once the akama comes
on they're starting
yeah and so think about what allah says
in the quran where you have the people
that go out into the ocean
on the sailboats
and
when the storms overtake them and
everything and they think that their
time is near they pray to allah and they
ask a lot for protection and just for
the safe travels to be able to make it
back home and then once they make it
back to land it's like
well all that goes out the door
right and so think about your own
situation your own life like
pretty sure there are things that you
ask allah for
we all do you know we make dua and we
ask allah okay make this easy for me um
bless me here take care of this song
whatever the case may be right and allah
answers this allah provides exactly what
you asked for in one way shape or form
or maybe provide something that you know
you need even more so than that
and what was crazy is that you ask allah
allah gives and then you
so that's like slapping the creator in
the face where it's like
you know you you go extra you go you
start going overtime where you start
making more dua you even start doing
istahada you even start doing the tahaju
you can start doing fajr every single
prayer on time
but then it's like once you get what you
asked for and what you wanted you stop
doing that
you know so
take it as like
if you want buttaka then you have to put
in the overtime work for allah
and
yeah and once you get that buttercup
like you gotta keep putting in that work
more paraka means more work you know
what i mean more power means more
responsibility more income means give
more salaka you know
look hella different
vlog i'm the la bro has come a long way
i mean but masha allah like figa if you
guys don't know what he's talking about
check out our our video that we dropped
today it's like a little teaser trailer
for the iceland vlog and then you know
watch the whole thing if you want to see
that more trips insha allah that we do
together right not just solo
um all right salam
have you heard the story of prophet [ __ ]
allah and how iblis actually literally
created music yet he created the first
musical instrument and uh he caused uh
so there were basically two tribes right
there were two groups um one with very
attractive men
and now really attractive women and the
other one had attractive women but not
really attractive men right and that's
that's what they they were given
everything was in harmony and the police
basically created musical instruments
and caused the attractive men from one
group to to basically pair bond with the
attractive woman from the other group of
vice versa and
there we go bro that dogs that dog's
hungry
no that's bro on a scooter passing by
listen you got some asians out here oh
my bad you got some ties out here where
they just cut the pipes off
so it's like they they run these little
like tiny scooters and they sound just
like these
these trucks bro i don't get it
if a female lacks interest in marriages
barely attracted to both genders i don't
know what you mean by attracted to both
genders should she marry or stay single
even though
she knows that she may not be able to
fulfill the rights of a husband
barely attracted to both genders i don't
know why it would matter if she's
attracted to the same gender
but so she's um
asexual
yeah
she's asexual i
listen
i think you should still marry
um but definitely make a lot of dua
that basically allah puts someone in
your life
that is also
of the same wave of the same energy
you know like that's also asexual you
know because at that point
um you guys would
definitely there would be barakah
in it for the both of you because you
know you guys have a higher purpose
but if you get with someone and you
don't pray
the prayer you don't ask a lot to give
that to you
well then you're probably going to end
up
in the situation that you're saying
where you're not going to be able to
fulfill the rights of a husband
alhamdulillah
all right next one so i'm going to
congratulate content what advice do you
have for someone who had difficulties to
have confidence
uh about the others and especially a
girl for marriage
oh no bro go in
put her back on the screen bro
about the others and especially a girl
from marriage
i'm not sure i understand
so how do you how do you give someone
that has confidence issues
kind of get that like get that boost in
their step bro get that confidence get
that they feel good and they feel amped
up how do you what advice would you have
bro
um
well i feel like that's different for
each person
but the first thing is uh
you know
it's really just having that full trust
and allah that's number one
and then the next thing that comes from
that
is uh
actually going out there and doing these
things
that
you don't have confidence in because
experience is what gives you confidence
you know like kobe bryant
kobe bryant
you know may
you see
and maybe judge accordingly
but uh
before he passed
he was asking an interview like why is
he why is he so confident and what he
does
and he said that
his confidence comes from his
preparation
and the fact that he was like
training for hours and hours and hours
and hours and hours and hours a day
and um if you think about it okay like
well
if you're not confident
let's say with women
have more experiences
of course you want to keep it a lot but
i have more experiences
that's really the only way
i agree with that bro and
for confidence bro there's two things
right there's con competence and then
there's worthiness
are you familiar with these two
yes so so for confidence
these are the two things that boost your
confidence competence and worthiness
competence is what anna was saying at
the end where it's like how skilled are
you in something right so competence is
like think of it like your actual stats
right like how smart you are how good
you are with with you know making money
and how uh let's say if you go into the
masjid things that are measurable per se
right so these are competence if if you
guys are stranded can you start a fire
right these are all skills this is
competence worthiness is more like
subjective like how you feel about
yourself security in a way right we live
in a world today where
a lot of people are being pushed by the
system to not really focus on competence
but just have this entitlement have
worthiness and only worthiness right
that's not good because you feel like
you have this entitlement complex where
you you deserve everything without doing
nothing
but the opposite's also not good where
you have a lot of competence but you
have no worthiness so you're good your
stats are really good alhamdulillah but
you you think you're still not good
enough you never know when to stop right
so i think striking a good neutral
balance between both and working on
those is very important
[Music]
yo i have a question why is the the daf
but
all of the instruments are not i can't
tell you bro i wouldn't know
i will look it up though and i'll get
back to you when i do know
any tips for making jin go out of body
uh
definitely
um
every time okay when i'm when i'm in
saudi in the haram
and
uh
during umrah let's say or even i forget
umrah bro just just praying just making
salat
uh let's say this one time
i was literally praying and
now you know what i think it was it was
maghrib
now
after the
the imam
uh read surah fatiha and and you know it
was just then reciting quran after that
um there was a woman next to me right um
because you can hear all the sisters
even though they're praying in separate
quarters she was literally screaming bro
it's a very normal thing very common
thing that you know a lot of sisters and
a lot of people wrote they go they go to
places like this and then when they're
in the haram
these jinjas get exorcised out of their
body bro because they're special verses
in the quran that are very powerful
and that the shaytin the jinn they don't
like whatsoever
women in particular more because you
know women are impure for a quarter of
their lives
it's a lot of time for for gen to you
know interact with them
at which time they can't pray they can't
touch the quran and stuff like that
right um in general and they're a little
more prone to evil eye and stuff like
that so a lot of protectors from that
and it's something you hear very
commonly about i heard the same thing
happen to a lot of men um but what i do
know is rookia bro go to someone proper
you can do rookie on yourself but it's
always better to have a lot of people
because when the gin are you know
disturbed and you're trying to basically
cast them out
there's a lot of things that could
happen bro that could be dangerous
then remember
answer
how would you answer this
um
i don't know
i think is it's probably because
we just don't have proper role models
so it goes with the generations before
us
i feel like the reason there's a lot of
secular muslims today is just because
secularism is a golden measuring stick
of reality today unfortunately and
people we have this ingrained hard-wired
thing to kind of not want to stray out
of the group at least most of us right
um unless you have your fitrah intact
but let's say if everyone was muslim
more people would be muslim right if
everyone uh is christian more people
just identify with christianity a lot of
christians don't even know why the heck
they're christian but they just know
it's a lot of people in my family
everyone right
um so anyway my point is
uh it's easy to be among uh most of us
and it's hard to be uh among the few i
believe um
basically
allah make us of the few you know what i
mean so it's not always a bad thing
all right honor bro how would you answer
john smith bro
first of all bro come on you could have
picked any pseudonym any fake name you
went with john smith bro
hmm
well i go salon
um you guys have any countries you're
playing and travel to with all
there you including ramy
uh
the first place will be the uk
or um
[Music]
here we go
ben personal is all music even the
sheets i don't know why we always get
this in every single stream bro so i
cannot speak on music in general because
music in general is there's a difference
in opinion bro like in sheets and all
that but what i do know for a fact is
musical instruments
are impermissible
there's a specific hadith where the
prophet
says that there will be people of my
ummah who one day aim to make stuff like
gambling fornication adultery
uh intoxicants
and the musical instruments permissible
hello
right so
how do you make how do you try to make
something permissible if it's already
permissible you can't right
the only
you know rational deduction is that it's
impermissible and there will be people
in my um that want to make it
permissible right so it's clearly
impermissible from the sahih hadith
um in islamic legislative authority uh
an authentic hadith has the same footing
as any ayah from the quran
right
so
we gotta follow it
that house we gotta follow it if you
don't like that okay then look at the
four major sunni schools of thought
before madaib
all four of them unanimously agree the
musical instruments are impermissible
right
if you don't want to follow them then
see what music does to you bro see what
music has done to society
right and
genuinely i understand that i know
people talk about buddhism and other
religions and or ways of life being like
they care more about the ego no bro
that's islam is the pinnacle of
controlling your nafs and your desires
what other religion do you know that
literally it's not strict if you look at
it like it's strict and it's trying to
control you that's different but
in a way you still you could still do
whatever you want to do you know what i
mean like they can listen to the stream
they can go listen to music they can
listen to the stream they can go out and
party and drink we don't advise that
obviously but they can
but here's the thing no one's forcing
you bro if you feel bad or controlled
it's because a part of you actually
agrees and understands that this is the
truth
so it's not a bad thing bro and if you
feel some type of way about music
you know just
take a step in the right direction every
day that's all i'm going to say
does angel live on a farm
no
i'm just
i'm in thailand right now i'm in the
mountains
so
[Music]
i'm sitting right here and this is a
rice field you've got the mountains over
there you got cows dogs
all that stuff
um
i mean right there's this narrative in
the west that if you speak out against
lgbt it may it means you're secretly gay
thoughts nah bro that's uh
check out a video that we made a podcast
it's called shaming tactics right
so society uses these things called
shaming tactics to basically make you
not propagate the truth so if you are
belittling someone's masculinity it
means you have a fragile masculinity
what the hell does that even mean bro
or if you're homophobic then you're
secretly gay what
how does that make sense
yeah but
again let's be literally
if you speak out you're not belittling
that that in and of itself
would be a shaming tag to give that's
not what you're doing you know what i'm
saying
if you're just saying like the truth
about it
well that's what you're doing you're
telling the truth about it and it's just
really seeing that as belittling well
then that's on them you know they're the
ones that are just saying that
so you gotta you gotta stand for
something
or is he gonna fall for anything
um
am writes the amish do not allow music
because they believe it excites the
emotions
hmm
that's true
definitely angel went on the dean show
so if you guys want to check a little
bit more on that he spoke about music
and empathy and sympathy with eddie from
the dean show so just search just search
up
the dean show on her although he didn't
mention
angel anywhere i think it just said
drake uses hot sauce mela bless eddie
either way he's uh he's a close brother
of ours
[Music]
i think it's crazy like when there's so
much light it overexposes and it makes
me look like a ghost
yeah that's true bro that's true
malik
allah
there we go bro
oh okay what else
what do you think of red pill red pill
what is that have you ever heard of that
red pill
what is red pill like uh
painkiller like a
tylenol what's he talking about
come on now bro we made too many videos
about red pokemon
check out our video literally titled our
thoughts on red pill something like that
[Music]
what if john smith is a revert
okay what if what if
what if what if john smith is a vegan
what do you want me to do about that
would you eat
we don't
would you guys be interested in having
the audience share their views on some
of your live videos through calling bro
that's it we got something we got
something planned we got something
planned we got something to plan
listen
cis or bro but i'm gonna say cis because
you got a pink wallpaper watch me cancel
for that
uh
a week ago or two weeks ago
yusha evans right this name started
coming up in a lot of recommendation
dm's we've been getting right
i've been having this vibe when we
started getting these dms it kind of
confirmed it but i still did i still
stayed cool i didn't question it
angel then randomly messaged not you
know
sending a video of you shavings or
anything he just sent the message on a
group chat
you know we should get you shavings on
inshallah and i was like
bro
the next day we go alive
and two people
recommended yusha evans
so it's like we're gonna take it aside
but anyway you're probably wondering
where are we going with this
so
we've been talking about trying to spice
up
our channel right
so there's a lot of things a lot of
people do right so currently what we're
doing is just podcast
reaction videos vlogs here and there
but in a way that's kind q as obviously
but that's kind of it right so
we've been thinking of doing like almost
like a call-in show but comment down
below let us know what you guys think of
this call-in show it's basically like
does it right
um a lot of you know
non-muslim channels do it right but
we're trying to take this to the next
level bro aren't we
inshallah we just got to figure it out
bro i'm not trying to have uh someone
join the stream out and then show
something uh provocative on the on the
screen bro
my brother that i
have randomly met halfway across the
world bro subhanallah
i know this brother so i was literally
in uh
in
in madina
on masjid and nawabi right literally
just just praying salah
and this brother just came up to me he's
like yo are you fired
i was like yeah and he's like salaam
alaikum bro i was
a lot bro like
where are you from bro like how like
what are you doing here and he's like oh
bro i just i recognized you because uh i
think he either said he saw an instagram
picture or a live stream and i was
wearing the same uh outfit the same soap
that i was wearing that day was the red
one
subhanallah bro small world but just the
fact that we can make these videos and
people like halfway across the world
recognize us bro
bro
all right guys we're gonna end it up in
uh about five ish minutes
so any more questions please let us know
it's live here's a test of willpower
marshall yes uh all the birds
i shall love all the birds chirping
and listen this is gonna sound insane
but over here
when it hits prayer times
the animals
start going crazy
like especially the birds they just
start chirping like crazy and like yeah
they chirp all the time but
specifically during the prayer times
like once a prayer time it's like they
all started like chirping like crazy
letting you know like yo it's time like
go like go play
no man i love about it bro malik i
didn't believe it
i didn't believe it like the brother
that i'm staying with he told me about
it i was like
okay but when i actually saw it and i
experienced it i was like oh my
shah um
ice cold jews bro you have to have a
name like bro name like that is fitna
bro
right now i'm gonna go have some juice
after that
but uh next question from abubini aside
from other topics of discussion how are
you two doing and everyone else here
i'll school for you good uh for your
father i'm the libra is good how are you
doing in terms of trying to get married
we'll see see what happens
what am i doing in thailand
i'm doing exactly what allah decreed for
us
he said
number one travel
across the nations
so that we can see the different nations
of different people
so that we can perhaps be
humble and proudly grateful
um and perhaps you know so we can
understand
what his greater plan is
and um
[Music]
hey the experience that i had it kind of
like
kind of sets it all in stone
and the biggest reason to why i decided
to start traveling
um
it was when i read surah al hajj
there's um i forgot what yeah it is
but i think i said this at one point
it's like
allah says uh
have they not traveled across the land
to see what happened to those before
them indeed it is the
it's not the eyes that are blind but it
is the heart
that goes by there's something like that
it's that one just kind of like opened
my eyes and like
this light bulb where i was like yeah i
i need
i need to travel i need to see
man look who aren't you the best in
marriage i think yeah
i mean and what oh no i don't know what
you're saying right now it's facts bro
most people
are not
physically blind they're spiritually
blind
thai food is so good bro what do you
think bro ty ty bro thai iced tea that
slaps
i haven't tried the iced tea yet but the
thai food is delicious
especially the the muslim thais
like they put like
i don't they put a twist into it in
there and then you got that buttercup
because they they put that love into it
when they're cooking offshore
no at first it was multiple
wallahi at first it was muay thai but it
all changed
[Music]
two more questions and then we are going
to wrap this up
until monday inshallah same time 7 p.m
eastern standard time
midnight uk time
uh when i say midnight 11 59 pm
uh every monday and friday right
i don't want someone waiting tuesday
night uk time when we're not going to be
there bro so
wow
where in tallaha give them give them the
exact coordinates bro
right now i mean
i think it's called
mahou
song or may song
it's it's in the mountains of pay by
however you say that
but um
yeah i'm just i'm here for a little bit
and i'll probably go back to phuket
marshall
who blinks i don't know who he's talking
about bro
come to indonesia bros
inshallah
1 o'clock here in new zealand
[Music]
may allah preserve you my dear brothers
[Music]
malik writes do you think performing
salah in nature can increase
concentration almost like meditation in
a sense
yes
yes we should always strive to
do the
prayers in the mosque but like sunnah
prayers or
anything else like do it in nature
it'll hit different for sure
hello mubarak for sure
nice background brother fired zakula
fair bro
that's called juice
martial
thank you so much for the super chat for
supporting the channel
alhamdulillah
come to washington dc
okay so first out of the two questions
we got
do you struggle concentrating
in salah
i think everyone does yes
definitely
i'm not gonna lie like
it's better to
concentrate in salah
than not concentrate
but then it's also better to praise a
lot even if you can't concentrate than
to not pray at all
to do without what you will some days i
don't feel i don't feel the best
concentrating wise i still just pray it
but i do practice and
aim and inspire every day every time i
pray to like
get that concentration down
and i think anna was talking about this
one day but we're all distracted by a
lot of different things around us and we
keep ourselves distracted um i am lucid
talks about this a lot on this channel
but basically when
when a lot of people are distracted
during the day it basically makes their
baseline concentration worse so when you
do try to do mundane things like pray or
fast or just read quran or read books or
study
your dope means just completely out of
whack bro
yeah speaking of i'm lucifer how's it
going with the brother
sound good
he's doing
humdinger i'm the lover did you reach
out to him
indeed
all right bro we'll keep uh we'll keep
you posted then inshallah
all right
our last question
and i like to live in thailand
everyone over there
a lot of muslims over here brother
there are a lot of buddhists for sure
but there's a lot of muslims like i
didn't think there were that many
muslims out here
more muslims in america more muslims
than in america
in my opinion
um
okay if you are having difficulties
concentrating on salah i would recommend
the book by evan allen
the inner dimensions of the prayer i'm
gonna look into that myself
yeah it sounds something i'm taking a
screenshot of that
send me that screenshot too bro
all right last thing we were going to
address
in writes there's a hadith that actually
states that the best place to go is to
the mountains and just take care of
yourself and fam when there is fitna and
around everyone and you can't escape it
so respect masha allah
wasn't that the thing when the jag comes
to go to the mountains
and get some sheep
and live like the people that live in
the mountains yeah so like just just
take off and just live like the bedouins
you know
yeah
yeah
all right guys if you made it before i
don't know what should the hashtag be
hashtag
charizard if you know you know
alhamdulillah and i don't want anyone
making meme out of that definitely but
until next time monday go make it
and now i'm gonna make it bro monday and
friday inshallah seven pm houston center
time
two days a week live inshallah soon so
the call in show right so uh just
letting you guys know
if you are going to be part of the clown
show if you're going to come on the
channel just come on just don't do
anything reckless all right if you if
you hate islam
and you're a hater
just pro just just do something else
with your date bro don't waste your
evening
with us losers and try to ruin the
stream
like come on bro you're better than that
if you hate islam so much and you just
have so much you know more to do with
your life than just bro if you could do
better than do better
you know
yeah
and with that being said
assalamu